un discours prononcé ce dimanche le
guide suprême ali khamenei refuser
l'aide américaine et évoque même une
théorie du complot impliquant washington
malgré la gravité de la situation
la crise entre les deux pays semblent
loin d'être terminés
soit on aime soit moins bricoleurs à
vous les américains est accusée d'avoir
produit ce virus mais je ne sais pas à
quel point cette accusation est vrai
mais quand une telle accusation existe
pourquoi les gens raisonnables
devrait-il vous faire confiance pour la
fourniture d'un médicament goutte d'or
où washington a proposé ces derniers
jours une aide humanitaire à l'iran son
ennemi de longue date pays actuellement
le plus touché du moyen-orient depuis le
début de la crise sanitaire avec 1685
morts et plus de 21000 cas des chiffres
officiels
sérieusement remises en doute par une
partie de l'opposition
le conseil national de la résistance
iranienne
actuellement en exil évoqué ce dimanche
dans un communiqué un bilan qui
dépasserait les 8800 mort des
informations invérifiables de sur place
si elles ont recommandé de rester
confinés les autorités iraniennes n'ont
toujours pas imposer de mesures de
quarantaine obligatoire dans les rues de
téhéran
comme dans tout le pays les iraniens
sont censés célébrer ce week end le
nouvel an persan une fête durant
laquelle les familles se rassemblent aux
quatre coins du pays
je ne pense pas que la plupart des gens
auront une vraie fête cette année toutes
les entreprises ont été durement touchés
par l'épidémie
j'avais l'habitude de rentrer chez moi
dans la province du nord de l'iran
chaque année mais cette année je ferais
mieux de ne pas y aller
j'ai aussi dit à mes amis de rester chez
eux pour ce nouvel an mon seul souhait
que tout le monde y compris moi et ma
famille soit en bonne santé
j'espère que personne ne souffrira de
malheur et que l'épidémie prendra fin le
plus tôt possible
malgré les recommandations des autorités
selon le croissant rouge iranien
2 3 millions de personnes ont pris la
route afin de rejoindre leurs proches
pour le nouvel an renforçant ainsi le
risque d'une expansion de l'épidémie
après le discours de l'ayatollah ali
khamenei ce dimanche l'iran en plus
d'être frappé de plein fouet par
l'épidémie se retrouve une fois de plus
fortement isolé sur le plan
international